la mauvaise gestion des ressources est
un vrai problème est particulièrement en
afrique je vais vous parler du domaine
que je connais le mieux qui sont les
ressources humaines la ressource humaine
pour être exact de mon point de vue la
ressource humaine et la passe l'essence
même de tous nous pourrions la définir
ainsi comme un ensemble d'individualités
doué de codes sociaux et de
connaissances et de potentiel négliger
là et c'est tout un pays qui souffre à
l'échelle de l'entreprise vous risquez
au mieux de ne pas honorer vos délais et
au pire de perdre des clients et donc du
chiffre d'affaires je vais vous le
démontrer
si je vous demande comment augmenter vos
profits vous allez me dire par
l'augmentation des ventes ou en
augmentant notre productivité ou encore
en réduisant vos coups à tout sont de
bonnes réponses avec qui ne seront
possibles que si et seulement si vous
avez l'armée de talent qu'il vous faut
vous avez beau implanter les meilleurs
process avant les meilleures machines
les meilleures technologies si vous
n'avez pas les hommes et les femmes que
dont vous avez besoin pour pouvoir
régler ces machines la meilleure
innovation le meilleur produit ne sera
jamais vendu ou ne sera jamais créé pour
faire court sans steve jobs l'iphone
n'aurait jamais existé
je ne partagerais pas avec vous
aujourd'hui une solution miracle mais
plutôt des pistes de réflexion celle que
bien gérer vos coûts passe d'abord par
bien gérer vos hommes
là je voudrais juste parlé un petit peu
de
de vous qui ne passe pas au moins une
heure sur vos tableaux excel à faire des
macros à regarder vos copines à regarder
vos vos performances soyons honnêtes qui
je pense qu'à peu près tous alors
pourquoi vous ne faites pas pareil pour
vos ressources humaines pour analyser la
gestion de vos talons avez vous déjà
pensé à calculer votre retour sur
investissement en analysant chaque
talent ce que chaque talent on peut vous
apporter un recrutement efficient est un
recrutement qui a su bien gérer des
ressources humaines et financières tout
au long du processus
pourtant toutes les fonctions de
l'entreprise
les rh sont celles qui connaissent le
moins bien leur poule elles sont
attachées de plein de coûts cachés et
s'il est difficile pour une entreprise
de calculer ses coûts et surtout d'une
entreprise à une autre de calcul et de
faire une vraie analyse de marché
cela peut quand même se faire en interne
et cela peut s'analyser par embaucher
par type de poste
prenons l'exemple si un poste est vacant
cela entraîne nécessairement une en
baisse du chiffre d'affaires puisque
vous avez donc du surtravail pour les
collaborateurs un manque à gagner un
manque de production et
du coup
juste prenez un peu de réflexion et
demandez vous combien perdez vous chaque
année avec tous ces postes que ne vous
n'arrivez pas à a recruté
remplacer un employé performant au
moment de son départ tout 0,5 à 2 fois
son salaire annuel c'est bon à savoir
donc
combien de départs avait subi cette
année et combien de chiffre d'affaires
avez vous perdu cette année certains
postes ont du mal à attirer les talents
nécessaires et nous avons de plus en
plus de mal en côte d'ivoire côté
certain talent on peut penser à la
quille on peut penser à l'ingénierie on
peut penser à certains métiers
techniques de la banque par exemple
une entreprise qui ne parvient pas à
voir ça 'pipeline' de talent ne sera
jamais capable d'atteindre son
performances optimum soyons clair
combien de postes n'arrivez pas à vous
par à recruter chaque année par manque
de talent
au total combien avez vous perdu cette
année si vous refaites un petit recul et
que vous calculez les départs que vous
calculez les embauches que vous n'avez
pas réussi à recruter et les talents
dont vous manqué combien avez vous perdu
moi je vous le dire des centaines de
millions de francs
le recrutement est clairement un enjeux
business si vous investissez
intelligemment de l'homme vous déclarez
vos performances de vos projets si vous
les négligés vous en trouvez
nécessairement dans une spirale
infernale
de coûts et donc de perte de rentabilité
alors maintenant que je vous ai dit tout
ça il faudrait savoir comment savoir si
votre investissement humain est rentable
et nous allons apporter à aborder un
petit peu le là le principe du causse
par ailleurs où le coût du recrutement
vous devez tous avoir un coût
d'acquisition client avec un budget
commercial que vous allez dépenser pour
chaque client alors je vous demande
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas un
coût d'acquisition client coût
d'acquisition talent
sauriez vous me répondre si vous avez
justement ce budget préalable défini ou
plutôt savez vous identifier ses coûts
pour le calcul est une entreprise doit
inclure tous les coups qui ont été mis
en place pour faire ce recrutement si on
commence à réfléchir un petit peu on
voit que ça fait une très longue liste
alors nous allons juste prendre un
rapide exemple nous avons gens qui est
directeur des ressources humaines chez
ivoire industrie et il a pour objectif
de faire x e recrutement dans l'année
pour ce faire il doit calculer son
budget est aussi le coup préalable que
ce recrutement va coûter donc il va
devoir ajuster tout simplement toutes
les tâches qui est toutes les personnes
qui seront impliquées dans son
recrutement
donc vous allez avoir tous les
opérationnels et les rh qui ont un lien
avec le recrutement vous allez avoir le
temps passé à la direction par la
direction à débloquer les budget et à
définir l'offre vous allez avoir les
coûts publié les coûts liés à la
publication de l'offre à la
communication vous allez avoir le temps
passer pour la sélection des cv des
entretiens premier entretien deuxième
entretien un troisième entretien le coût
des tests aussi psychologique
psychotechniques
performance
test de moralité le temps passé aux
entretiens à la validation de l'offre à
la contre-offre à la signature du
contrat
les procédures administratives les
procédures juridiques la négociation
salariale
ok là maintenant la personne vient de
signer ou fttu va bien sauf que à ce
stade vous avez dépensé beaucoup
d'argent vous avez dépensé beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup d'énergie des
collaborateurs mais en tout cas la
personne à date n'est pas encore
productif
vous n'avez pas encore calculé son coup
d'intégration eh oui la personne n'est
pas immédiatement efficace il lui faut
un certain temps pour ça pour
apprivoiser votre mac votre structure
vos collaborateurs il lui faut du temps
pour s'imprégner de vos process et selon
une étude du hem haïti il faut environ
huit à vingt six semaines pour qu'une
recrue de vienne à peu près productive
d'accord on a intégré le coût
d'intégration mais vous n'avez pas non
plus intégrer le coût des business
manquiez où le déficit de productivité
qui est lié au manque de postes ou à
l'absence de cette personne et aux
collaborateurs qui sont sur staff et
donc vous voyez que tous ces coûts
cachés
englober peuvent revenir très cher et
d'autant plus que c'est un enjeu et
c'est un risque personne ne sait si ce
recrutement va marcher
il ya peu d'études en afrique a sur ce
sujet et très honnêtement très peu
d'études global aussi car sûrement c'est
difficile à calculer mais j'ai pu
récupérer quelques chiffres si on prend
l'exemple de la france attire des
embauches seront plus dans l'année qui
suit donc le recrutement a été un pari
et rien ne garantit que tous les
investissements que vous avez fait pour
apporter ses fruits
et s'il échoue à vous devez reprendre
tous de zéro vous pouvez estimer que
votre héros y devient négatif et surtout
que vous créez une risque une baisse de
la productivité une baisse des morales
des collaborateurs une baisse d'énergie
une altération aussi de votre image
auprès de vos clients
tous ces retours deviennent négatifs et
le coût évalué on parle de 15 fois le
coût de la personne embauchée en moyenne
donc maintenant que nous avons un petit
peu abordé le coût du recrutement
j'aimerais aussi abordé l'idée d'y de la
guerre des talents côte d'ivoire la
guerre des talents bat son plein et
j'aimerais
vous dire que pour être compétitif et
pour investir pour être le plus
compétitif dans les sociétés actuelles
il faut absolument investir dans les
talents et donc ça veut dire
nécessairement augmenter vos coûts de
recrutement ou votre nombre de
recrutements par exemple si l'on prend
l'un des succès d'apple c'est
privilégier la qualité à la quantité
chaque produit apple qui a été créée a
été créé par deux toutes petites équipes
pour limiter les durées de process
augmenter la créativité augmenter la
rapidité
et l'efficacité
donc vous voyez que le retour sur
investissement du recrutement n'est pas
forcément très compliqué il faut
contrôler les risques rationaliser
l'ingéniosité et ça ne recrutait ne
nécessite pas nécessairement un gros
volume mais surtout de la qualité
alors comment
si on reprend les tendances de la côte
d'ivoire vous allez voir que c'est un
pays en pleine croissance que c'est un
pays dynamique que c'est un pays jeune
et très adaptable
comment attirer cet allant d'abord par
sont réellement extérieur il est
rentable d'investir massivement dans sa
marque employeur je pense que vous le
savez tous si une marque employeur est
bien orchestré elle deviendra un élément
naturel
de vos candidats
si on prend l'exemple de google sachez
que google reçoit 3,3 million de
candidatures par an
soit la population totale de l'erythrée
où la population totale de dakar vous
vous donner un petit peu une idée du
nombre de personnes qui postulent pour
travailler chez google
si vous avez une entreprise qui jouit
d'une aura d'une marque employeur forte
vous aurez en moyenne 30% de départs en
moins
linkedin le dit une bonne marque
employeur déclare
déclare en cours de recrutement deux
fois moins élevé ce qui est très
important pour beaucoup de productivité
une marque employeur forte peut vous
aider aussi à faire la différence et
vous aider à vous éviter de faire deux
seulement investir dans le salaire pour
convaincre candidats vous n'avez
peut-être pas de voiture de fonction à
proposer ou vous n'avez peut-être pas un
parcours
avec beaucoup de bénéfices à proposer
mais peut-être que vous avez vous
proposer à un plan de performance et de
compétences peut-être que vous proposez
un avenir peut-être que vous avez des
valeurs qui peuvent attirer vos
candidats vous n'avez peut-être pas le
ps a l'air à proposer mais vous avez
peut-être un plan réel de développement
et ça aussi ça peut jouer tout ne se
joue pas sur l'argent et les avantages
une autre idée peut-être le recrutement
collaboratif on est à l'heure du parc
funding et des réseaux sociaux alors
pourquoi ne pas réduire les coûts en
partageant les responsabilités à tous
aux opérationnels au manager ou rh que
tout soit impliqué dans ce recrutement
si on prenait reprendre l'exemple de
google à vrai dire sachez que google
implique absolument tous et
opérationnelle dans tout le processus de
recrutement il se base sur les tops
performeur sur les au talent pour créer
la fiche de poste à leur image ils
préparent ensemble les questions imposé
lors des entretiens et ils font aussi
une ans une enquête de satisfaction sur
le déroulement des entretiens prix
bon vous serez d'accord avec moi tout
cela est long comme un digestif mais le
coût de recrutement diminue par
l'ingéniosité tout simplement on n'a pas
nécessairement besoin d'avoir beaucoup
d'argent mais que ce soit par la
digitalisation le sourcing ou le
recrutement extérieur il faut bien avant
tout connaître son business connaître
ses valeurs connaître son col ses
collaborateurs et c'est en faisant un
effort de collaboration entre opérations
et recruteurs qu'on arrivera à avoir une
bonne stratégie de talent et diminuer
ses coûts de recrutement si on reprend
un autre exemple qui est un peu un peu
plus amusant si vous avez regardé le
film the social network le film de
facebook vous voyez à un psy vous
reprenez cette partie bon je ne sais pas
si l'histoire est vraie je n'ai pas les
moyens de savoir mme en tout cas ce qui
est dit dans le film c'est que mark
zuckerberg au moment où il lance
facebook et qu'il commence à être en
plein développement il a besoin de
recruter des programmeurs comme c'est
une start up il y aura beaucoup de
travail / ame une cadence très intense
donc son choix de recrutement et de
faire programmer ses programmeurs sans
arrêter et le tout en leur faisant boire
de l'alcool
donc le et celui qui arrivera à tenir le
plus longtemps sans dormir tout en
programmant tout en buvant de l'alcool
sera celui qui a gagné donc évidemment
je ne suis pas en train de vous dire que
pour vos recrutements il faut faire
boire les gens pas du tout mais là on a
un exemple encore une fois de de
l'ingéniosité et de la spécificité
propre aux besoins de l'entreprise c'est
à dire qu'ils avaient besoin d'avoir des
personnes qui savait travailler sous
pression un qui travaillaient qu'il
s'agit était capable de tata cumulé une
forte masse de travail qui étaient
capables de travailler dans des
conditions aussi difficiles et du coup
pourquoi ne pas adapter vos recrutements
à ces valeurs là c'est à dire que si
vous recherchez un créatif
fait un recrutement qui vous assure que
vous à roques retrait des créatifs si
vous avez la valeur de ce la solidarité
est importante pour vous utilisez vos
recrutements de manière à ce que cette
valeur de la solidarité soit révélée il
ya bien d'autres techniques et ce sera
aussi vous mentir que de dire que la
base tout est à la base de la ressource
humaine bien évidemment non même si
l'homme est une base est une condition
indispensable
augmentez vos profits passe surtout et
avant tout par améliorer l'ensemble des
variables de votre rentabilité
et ce sera aussi vous mentir de vous
dire que il ne faut pas vous avez
orienté aussi vers l'amélioration
continue ouvert tous les domaines de
l'entreprise
de productivité et de performance
aujourd'hui j'ai abordé avec vous le
coût du recrutement comme potentiel
gisements de profit et de rentabilité ce
sont juste des idées de réflexion sur
comment l'aborder évidemment
intelligemment et maintenant que je vous
ai un petit peu dit ça ce que j'aimerais
prendre à ces cinq minutes de votre
temps et voir si vous seriez capable de
calculer vos ressources humaines et le
coût de vos ressources l'année dernière
est ce que vous avez fait le bon choix
quand vous avez choisi ce talent plutôt
qu'un autre pour assurer le
développement commercial ou votre
recherche et développement où en serait
votre business aujourd'hui si vous aviez
coq calculer votre budget ressources
humaines différemment et où en serait
notre chiffre d'affaires aujourd'hui est
ce que vous seriez aujourd'hui
positionnée dans les 500 pme de côte
d'ivoire
[Applaudissements]